There's a giant cloud of alcohol out there
in space just floating there… teasing us.
Is that the only way we're going to be able
to drink in space?!
Not… quite…
Happy Friday comrades, Trace here for DNews.
6500 light-years away, a giant cloud of alcohol
is floating in space.
Just… hanging out.
Alcohol is a mix of hydrogen, carbon and oxygen,
three extremely abundant elements, so to find
it out there isn't that surprising.
Finding it has astronomers excited, because
the cloud of alcohol has the exact conditions
required to trigger an astrophysical maser
-- like a LASER, but instead of LIGHT it's
MICROWAVES.
The people who wouldn't be excited are everyone
else, because the cloud is made of methyl
alcohol… not the kind you can drink.
But there is hope!
NASA cares deeply about the psychological
health of the astronauts, and a cold frothy
beverage is a great way to keep astronauts
mentally anchored to earth!
So, what about a having a drink in space?
Well, for NASA it's not really on the table.
We've talked a bit about drinking in space.
NASA has a pretty strict alcohol policy on
the ISS and on Shuttle missions, space is
dangerous, so being less than sober can cause
injury or death.
That being said, NASA researched a sherry
wine to go up to SkyLab in the 70s, but it
never went to space.
Turns out, the smell of the wine made people
nauseated during testing and the astronauts
-- on short-term missions -- didn't really
care if they had alcohol.
After one astronaut made a public speech saying
they were looking into it, angry letters prompted
NASA to ban alcoholic beverages...
The Russians, on the other hand, very famously
had cognac on Mir and supposedly rationed
about 4 ounces per day… supposedly… *wink*
There is some science to support alcohol in
space.
A 2011 paper in the Federation of American
Societies for Experimental Biology found resveratrol,
a component of some alcohols, can prevent
significant bone density, muscle and metabolic
losses during spaceflight!
Even though the astronauts can't wet their
whistles that doesn't mean there isn't SCIENCE
TO BE HAD!
A Scottish whiskey distillery named Ardbeg
shot 20 test tubes into space to test the
effects of microgravity on whiskey terpenes
back in 2011.
They're scheduled to come down TODAY.
A terpene is an organic molecule that is part
of whiskey maturation.
It’s a naturally occurring hydrocarbon that
can be found in termites, butterflies, hop
plants, pine tar and even paint thinners…it
helps give whiskey its flavor.
When the space-matured whiskey lands it'll
be tested against control whiskey molecules
that have been chilling here on Earth to learn
more about how distilling works.
It wasn't just whiskey either, experiments
have been done to explore how yeast behave
during fermentation, how foam and bubbles
behave in space, and even how a gas-liquid
mixture would behave in microgravity!
Turns out, beer doesn't work in space, nor
does any other carbonated beverage.
Coca-cola partnered with a company called
BioServe to try it out on the shuttle, and
it worked… okay.
The word they used was "palatable."
Do you think astronauts should be able have
a glass of wine with their re-hydrated dinner?
Should we let them get wastey-face up there?!
What would you want?
Have a cold one and spill your thoughts into
the comments here.
We want to hear them!
And check out my and Tara's other show TestTube
where we breakdown politics, world events
and curiosity about complicated news.
Like this one on whether we can trust
the Russian media…
Thanks for watching DNews!
Please subscribe.